hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in meditation 3 Rene Descartes will make
a distinction between different kinds of
reality between what he calls objective
reality and he's got several different
terms formal or actual or sometimes he
also talks about eminent reality as well
and the distinction that he makes very
easily trips up late modern readers in
part because the way that he's using the
term objective in his time which was
kind of a regular usage is almost
opposite of what we have in mind when we
hear somebody talking about objectivity
or objective reality or anything along
those lines so let's talk first about
what it is that he means by these terms
and then we need to discuss why these
distinctions are so important not only
within cartesian metaphysics as a whole
his attempt to sort of reconstruct
knowledge but also for the argument that
he's making in meditation 3 which is
going to give him the existence of God
and God not being a deceiver which then
allows him to read
construct the possibility of knowledge
of the external world so what do we mean
by objective reality let's start where
we are typically today when we say
objective reality or objectivity
typically what we have in mind although
sometimes we have to like think this
through because we use these words and
careless ways and rather vague senses
when we think it through what we usually
come up with is whatever is is there
whatever is being referred to should be
the same for me as it is for you as it
is for anybody else everybody should be
able to observe the same thing there's a
kind of constancy there's a kind of
universality to it right and why would
that be the case because it really does
exist that way out there in reality
whatever reality happens to be so when
we talk about being objective
we typically contrast that against being
subjective right and the subjective
would be something that's just in my
head and doesn't correspond to the
reality out there and we could talk
about the objective realities being
interpreted in multiple ways and biases
that people have and okay so that's how
we use the term that is not what
Descartes means by the term take heart
means in some respects almost the exact
opposite he is talking about what we
would call subjectivity but not a
subjectivity that's a pure arbitrariness
or something to be dismissed because it
only belongs to an individual rather he
is talking about object objectivity or
objective reality if we want to be very
clear objective reality is the reality
that things have as ideas in the mind
that is in terms of their representation
so the idea that I have of God or of
Descartes or of my body or of hydrogen
atoms or any of those sorts of things
the idea existing in my mind has
objective reality and this is well worth
you know dwelling on for a moment a lot
of people tend to think of
ideas is really being kind of nothing
and the outside things are what matter
well that's not the case at all ideas
are real they have a reality as ideas
within our mind right it's not that
they're nothing otherwise they couldn't
have the distinctness that they have
they couldn't have what Descartes calls
clarity their capacity to impose
themselves upon us to provide us with a
certain kind of self evidence the people
who dismiss what's in our heads as oh
that's just figments of your imagination
they don't know what they're talking
about ideas have reality as ideas that
is in fact a way of existing within
one's thought or mind so that's very
important objective reality is the
reality that something has as a
representation as an idea of the mind
what do we contrast to that the reality
that something would have say out there
in the world and that is what Descartes
typically calls formal reality he will
also use the term actual in a few places
and he will also talk about something
being eminent now being eminent means
that it's not completely active as
formal but it's sort of potentially
there right so ideas have a certain
eminent reality within within you know
they're there what could originate them
you could say but isn't necessarily
originating them at the moment be that
as it may formal reality is what we
would typically call objective reality
it's the the existence of the thing
independent of observers out there in
the world right so this is an incredibly
important distinction that he is making
here and he goes on and he's talking
here in the third meditation about
different kinds of ideas that we have in
our mind and another thing that's that's
really characteristic about this is
not only do ideas have objective reality
some ideas have more objective reality
than other ideas there is what we could
call a hierarchy of objective reality
and for Descartes
this has to do with what he calls their
degree of perfection that is being
brought to fulfillment and he says if we
consider images of which you know these
over here represent one thing and others
another it is evident that they are very
different between themselves why because
as it stands those that represent
substances he says are without a doubt
something more and contain in themselves
so to speak
a greater degree of being than or
perfection than those which represent
merely what he calls modes or accidents
so what is he talking about here a
substance would be something like for
example a book or myself or this
chalkboard or a light or whatever it
happens to be those are extended
substances the mind itself is a thinking
substance right so a human being is a
substance as well and the thoughts that
you have would in fact be modes or
accidents when he says accidents he
means this in the scholastic sense is
something that can be attributed to that
substance something that belongs to it
but is not the totality of that
substance and could be removed from it
so I'm thinking right now about Rene
Descartes imagining him in my head with
his you know little smirk that a that he
has in his painting okay I that thought
that I have is a mode of my substance as
a thinking thing and if you're thinking
about that the substance that is me the
thinking thing that has a greater degree
of he would say objective reality than
the thought of Rene
Descartes and the painting of him with
his little smirk right and we could we
might go further and further down
Descartes doesn't worry about this he's
interested primarily in establishing the
fact that there are degrees of being or
perfection or objective reality for
different sorts of things that we have
as ideas so already we've got substances
and by this he means finite substances
primarily because he can compare it to
another kind of substance which he calls
God so he says in addition to this that
by which I conceive a sovereign God
eternal infinite immovable all-knowing
all-powerful the universal creator of
all things which are outside of myself
that I say has certainly in itself more
reality more objective reality than
those of finite substances that are
represented to me
now all of this is still at the level of
ideas so he's not yet saying that there
is a God out there whose greater than
everything he's saying considered as an
idea that idea not only has a certain
you know greater value it has a greater
objective reality than those of finite
substances finite substances in turn
have a greater objective reality than
those of modes or accidents of
substances and in turn modes or
accidents of substances have a greater
degree of objective reality than the
idea of nothing nay on which Descartes
brings up quite a few times in the
meditations so now we have this
hierarchy established and as it turns
out the hierarchy mirrors that of formal
reality because in formal reality really
existing out outside of just our minds
if there is a God God is going to be on
top of the the hierarchy and then
substances things that are real that
that
other things can be in or be predicated
of how are we going to frame it those
are going to be less less real than God
but still quite real and then we have
modes or accidents of substances less
real and then finally we get down to
nothing not really real at all so
whether we're considering it in terms of
objective reality or formal reality we
have according to Descartes this sort of
hierarchy in place he goes on and he
says now it's something that's manifest
by the natural light that there has to
be at least as much reality in the
efficient and total cause than is in its
effect because where else would it get
that reality from other than its cause
now when it comes to formal reality
things existing in the world that's not
that hard of a cell for us to accept
right there has to be at least as much
reality in the cause as there is in the
effect because otherwise how are you
going to get the effect de kirk goes on
further and he says that this doesn't
just apply to what we can talk about as
you know one thing that possesses in
itself formally or eminently whatever is
in the composition of the thing that its
producing he is the example of a stone
but he says that this applies just as
much to our ideas so that this applies
just as much to objective reality
effects cannot come from causes that
would have less reality or perfection
objectively speaking than they would in
any other case so this is particularly
important Descartes is going to use this
as a linchpin in his argument for the
existence of God which is going to
depend on this interplay between
objective and formal reality
you